TODD KERPELMAN: We
would like to bring up
our last speaker of the day,
the fine gentleman in the back.
This is RJ Mical.
He is a brilliant
guy who has lots
of brilliant ideas
about the future,
and he is going to share
some of them with you now.
So just a quick little wrap-up.
It will most likely
be mind blowing,
if it's like any other
conversation I've had with RJ.
And so with that,
let's welcome RJ Mical.
[APPLAUSE]
RJ MICAL: Thank you, sir.
Thank you very much.
Hi, everyone.
Well, I'm here to make an
impassioned plea to you
today to make the strongest
request to Android developers
that I can make.
But let me start
first by talking
about where I think
everything is going.
We have this vision for where
games and entertainment,
in general, is
going, and I'd like
to start by sharing
that with you now.
Is there a microphone
I can walk around with?
I guess I can take this.
No?
That's all right.
I'll stand here.
I'm just not used to standing
still when I talk, you see.
So in the beginning,
there were games.
I mean, games go
all the way back
to caveman pushing stones
around on platforms of rock.
And in our beginning, in the
beginning of our industry,
there were games.
A long time ago, this
amazing, this miraculous thing
happened to our
industry, to our lives,
to our entire civilization.
And it started way
long time ago when
we started using
personal computers
for our everyday work.
And we started having lots
of computers in our offices,
and they became prevalent.
There became quite
a large number
of people that were familiar
with the idea of computers
and were using them.
And then this amazing
thing happened
where we started taking
those computers home with us.
And we said that we
were taking them home
for games-- I mean, for work,
that we intended to take them
home from work, but
in fact, the truth
was that we were taking them
home so we could play games,
so that we could play
solitaire at first,
and then it got more
and more elaborate.
The games became more and
more sophisticated over time.
And a long time
ago, our computers
at work, our computers
at home, they
became powerful enough to do
all the spreadsheets and all
the word processing that we
ever would want to do with them.
But they didn't stop there.
They kept getting more
powerful, kept getting
more capabilities,
more features.
And why?
Because of games.
Because we wanted our games
to be richer, and better,
and more wonderful,
and more powerful.
And we had these
devices at home that
could do our simple work for
us, but we kept empowering them,
kept getting better graphics,
better audio capabilities,
because we did it
for entertainment.
We did it because of games.
And we believe at Google that
this miracle then happened.
The first revolution came on us.
There was suddenly
this world that
was filled with all of
this amazing graphics
and audio capabilities,
this hardware
that they could accomplish all
of these great things for us.
And this like soil, this
fertile-- this rich soil
was ready for an
amazing thing to happen.
And out of that soil
came the worldwide web.
We believe that
the worldwide web
exists because of
entertainment, that it exists
because our games drove
the ability for this stuff
to come into existence.
And we think that
the next revolution
is coming upon us right now.
It's coming upon us from
the fact that we're all
walking around now with the
equivalent of PlayStation 2's
in our pockets.
And a year from now, they're
going to be PlayStation
3's, and the year after that,
they're going to be PlayStation
4's.
We are now walking around with
this kind of awesome hardware
capability.
But instead of what it
used to be-- hardware
tethered to our offices or to
the walls and our homes-- now
it's mobile now it goes with
us everywhere, all of the time.
The worldwide web
came into existence
because we wanted to
connect with each other.
We wanted to be part
of that community.
We wanted to
entertain ourselves,
to find one another, to
play with one another.
We wanted to be loved.
We wanted to be
recognized, and we
wanted to be seen as the
beautiful people that we are.
And I think that that same
thing is happening now,
but it's happening in a newer,
richer, and most amazing way
that you can't
even imagine where
it's going, although I have
a few clues now that we've
seen so far here at Google.
But the next
revolution is coming.
And we don't know exactly
what it's going to look like,
but we know how it's
going to be powered.
It's going to be powered
with these devices
that we're walking around with.
We now have the compute
technology in our pockets
to allow ourselves to connect,
and to connect with each other,
to reach out to each other,
to share experiences,
to share knowledge and
information with each other,
to share entertainment with each
other in a way that's much more
dynamic, that's not
tethered to our homes,
but it happens
anywhere-- anywhere
we are, anytime we want, with
any small group of people,
with any large group of people.
It's a new way of looking at
each other and entertaining
each other and communicating
with each other that's
coming right around the corner.
And in my group
at Google, our job
is to get this to happen,
to help accelerate it,
to help put the
pieces in place that
will allow this new way of
communicating with each other
to become a reality, and also to
put together some examples that
show the world what it is
that we're talking about,
about where it's
all going and how
it's all going to fit together.
We think then that this
new thing that's coming
needs a name, and so we
branded it Entertainment 2.0.
It's where entertainment
really is going.
It's no longer just games as
we know and no longer tied
to our homes and to our offices,
but this new sort of cloud
of entertainment
that's coming at us,
where we have experiences
that don't have games that
have a clear beginning
and a clear end.
But instead where the
entertainment experiences
we have are these sort
of continuous stream
of an experience that
you jump in some time
and you play a little
bit here, and you leave,
and you come, and you
join it again later.
And now you have this
device, and it's a phone,
or it's a tablet.
And then later ,
you're at your home,
and now you're communicating
with the television,
and you're using your console
device on the television,
and it's all part of
the same experience.
It's all part of the same
game, even though it's
different aspects of
it, different ways
of looking at it.
But this stuff is coming at us.
One of the requirements for
this to be able to happen,
is that we need to open
standards, and open platforms,
and the ability to
create this stuff,
and to take control
of our own destiny,
and to fashion the
things that we need.
And this is why we
think that Android
is the perfect platform for
this because it is open.
It does allow us
to change things
and to make things work
the way that we want it to.
Plus, as you guys probably
have already seen,
both the Android development
team and the developer
support team,
they're highly tuned
to what's going on with you.
And they're constantly looking
for feedback and suggestions
and ways to improve the
system and make it better.
We spent a lot of
energy, so far making
Android robust as
a phone system,
with a robust operating
system, and make sure
that the device is solid.
Now the next way to reach out
is to get it better for games,
to make it better
for entertainment.
And that's part of what
my group's job is to do
is to make Android number
one in the game space.
And this is part of what I
want to ask you guys for today.
I'll make the bold
statement that I
believe the console era is dead.
I think we're at the
end of the console era.
Well, I mean, with
a grain of salt.
There will always be
console-like devices.
And there will always
be someone that's
trying to reach out and create
the bleeding-edge device.
And there will always be the
consumers that want that device
and are willing to pay
the extra money for it.
But what I think is that the
days of the major players
spending $500 million to
develop a new console that
lives on in your living
room for seven years,
those days are gone.
The thing that's coming now
is the kind of experience
that we have now with our
phones and with our tablets.
I think that's going to
happen with our televisions
next as well, where it needs
to be updated all the time.
It needs to be upgraded.
We as consumers,
we as game players
are no longer going
to be satisfied
with having the same
hunk of hardware
for seven, eight,
nine years in a row
as they're planning with the
current generation of stuff.
But instead, it's more like
our phones, and our tablets,
where we find ways to
update them and upgrade them
all the time.
And that whole
experience is going
to be reflected in the way
entertainment works as well.
That we're going to see
this next generation
of entertainment.
That is based on the
fact that there's
lots of different
hardware out there
and lots of different
kinds of capabilities,
and that we're going to
have to write games that
take into account
the fact that there's
many different displays,
many different units.
Today it's Android.
Tomorrow it'll be iOS.
Chrome's coming.
Maybe Windows will get
hooked into everything
that we're looking at in the
long run, because what we're
looking at is the big
picture of entertainment.
And what we're looking at is not
just what Android has to offer,
but instead what all
of Google has to offer.
And this, we think, is what
Entertainment 2.0 is really
all about.
Because today it's games.
But tomorrow it's going
to be something that's
integrated into
all of our lives.
And it's something that
becomes part of everything
we do every day, where the
entertainment, and the ads,
and the movies that you
watch, and the TV shows,
and all of it, becomes
part of a whole.
And the games just
naturally flow out
of the TV shows that we watch,
which flow out of the movies
that we watch.
I mean, we have
these wild dreams
for where it's all going.
And in our wildest
of dreams, we see
that TV shows are
coming where there's
that can of soda in the TV show.
And it's a generic one
that the producer puts in.
And when that TV show
is broadcast to you
on your device,
that generic can is
replaced with a can of soda
that's the brand that you want,
because that's the
thing that you like,
and the advertisers
are willing to pay
for that or any other sorts
of substitutions for ads that
are live in a movie or a TV
show or a game or any experience
that you're having.
That's a simple example
of where all of it's going
and how all of it ties together.
And we think that where
entertainment is really
going, where the big
value that Google
has to add over the next
decades, comes from the fact
that entertainment is going to
be woven into not just games,
but everything that
we've got around us,
and everything in particular,
that Google has to offer.
You look at Knowledge
Graph, Maps, Street View,
self-driving cars, Fiber,
Glass, all these other things
that are happening inside of
Google, tons of other stuff
that we can't even
talk about that's
coming with the next
generation stuff for us
to connect with each
other-- all the wearables,
everything that's coming at us.
Google has these
amazing resources
that we want to make
available to game developers.
As a great example-- AI.
We think that we
need a real AI that's
based on the kind of knowledge
that a company like Google
is able to accumulate
and that we can then
make available to
game developers
worldwide, where
you can incorporate
that kind of knowledge,
that kind of experience
with the human race into the
very design of your games.
And, well, I could tell you
jokes about self-driving cars,
but I'm already out of time.
But we've got huge ideas
where all of it's going.
But the big thing that I want to
ask you today, because I know I
am out of time,
so I'll stop here.
We need to find the right
magic, the right way,
to make this content
available to you guys.
I use the word "magic, " and
that's because that's how we
refer to it inside Google.
It's that Google magic,
that cloud of awesomeness
that Google has to offer
to all of civilization,
and, in particular to
you guys that you could
use in your entertainment, the
software that you put together,
and that you can make it better,
richer, more engaging, more
human, or make more money
off of it, because you found
clever ways to use our APIs
to include ads in your games,
or whatever.
We don't know.
What we're looking for
is answers from you guys.
And so what I'm hoping
is that all of you
will come find me after this.
I wish I put a slide together
with my email address on it,
but I don't have
one, unfortunately.
But I'll be around
for a while, if you
want to come up and find me or
get my address from these guys.
I'm at Google as well.
My LDAP is easy to remember.
It's gameman@google.com.
And it's a pretty
awesome email address
to have-- reflects what
the company thinks,
where it's going, and what
they would like our group
to try to accomplish.
And so my request to you is
please look at everything
that Google has to offer.
Look at what Android's
like for you now,
what the development
experience is
like, what it's like
to incorporate content.
The sort of stuff that
Colt was just showing you
is an awesome example
of the kind of response
that you're already getting
from the DevRel guys.
And they've done a
lot of this already.
I'm sure the framework
guys reach out
to everyone all
the time as well.
We're joining that group,
reaching out to you
and asking for your input,
asking for your advice
about how can we make
Google available to you
as game developers.
Over the next few months,
between now and I/O,
we're putting together some
really interesting example code
that we're going
to put out there
that shows some of the
stuff we're talking about,
how you could use Knowledge
Graph real time in a game,
how you can take advantage of
some of these other things that
are available from Google.
And so we won't just talk.
We'll have actual
examples for you to use.
But we ask you guys,
please, reach out to us
and let us know what you want
and how you can use Google
to empower yourselves and
make your games even better.
So that's it.
That's the end of
my speech for today.
Are we taking questions?
Or there's not
time for questions.
All right.
So we're out of here.
We're out of here.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
TODD KERPELMAN: Thank you, RJ.
All right, raise your hand if
you learned something today.
All right, raise
your hand if you're
excited to go get
some beer somewhere.
All right, just as many of you.
Thank you so much for coming.
Thank you, everybody,
on the live stream,
and we will see you next year.